[Musique]
l'hémicycle du département est devenu le
temps d'une après-midi une salle de
cours d'histoire
une classe de représentants d'élus de
tous les collèges de l'île avec un
professeur prosper eve spécialiste de la
départementalisation de 1946 le
département a l'habitude de prendre part
à la commémoration des grandes dates de
l'histoire de la réunion
on démarre une opération
intergénérationnel puisqu'elle consiste
à mettre en relation des témoins deux
des 75 ans de la départementalisation
dans divers domaines l'économie la santé
le sport l'agriculture la culture la
remise à niveau et studieuse car la
départementalisation de la réunion est
une goutte d'eau dont le programme
d'histoire enseignés au collège il n'y a
pas beaucoup de jeunes qui savent ce qui
est de la départementalisation est
pourquoi elle a été mise en place à la
réunion c'est parfois chiant d'apprendre
des dates au collège et que ce n'est pas
toujours intéressant pour certains quand
même s'intéresser un minimum parce que
ça reste important pour nous en tant que
jeunes de savoir et de transmettre aussi
à d'autres jeunes et aux générations
futures une interaction évidente devant
un public de bon élève pourtant c'est
toute une génération qu'il faut
convaincre du rôle central de notre
histoire
qu'est ce qui nous manque c'est l'amour
quoi ce pays
et si l'on veut développer ce pays il
faut l'aimer et si on aime ce pays
on aime son histoire et on aime toutes
les étapes de son histoire
s'aimer soi même aimer les autres quoi
pouvoir grandir et construire un avenir
qu'ils soient plus radieux
et
avec beaucoup de bienveillance le
professeur transforme l'histoire en
philosophie sociologie ethnologie une
pluralité dans laquelle cette génération
doit inscrire sa singularité
[Musique]